[Musik]
wenn ich euch bitten würde mit den namen
einer aufstrebenden weltmacht zu nennen
wäre die allererste antwort wohl die
volksrepublik china aber was heißt hier
eigentlich weltmacht eine industrie und
export macht zweifellos eine
demografische macht zurzeit noch auf
jeden fall eine wirtschaftsmacht klar
nicht unbeträchtlich aber ist china auch
eine militärmacht von weltrang nun genau
auf diese brennende frage werden wir uns
heute konzentrieren wie geht die
militärische entwicklung des asiatischen
riesen voran stehen wir bereits vor der
bewachten globalisierung aus china und
vor allem wie schnell das reich der
mitte im vergleich zu den usa ab sie zum
beispiel mal diese grafik an
[Musik]
das basis militärbudget der usa betrug
im jahr 2020
778 milliarden dollar während chinas
ausgaben kaum 250 milliarden dollar
überschritten mit anderen worten andris
m bringt aktuell mehr als das dreifache
der chinesischen verteidigungsausgaben
auf die waage das ist auch nicht weiter
verwunderlich denn der militärhaushalt
der usa ist so gewaltig dass er die
budgets vorne china indien russland
großbritannien saudi arabien deutschland
frankreich japan südkorea italien und
australien zusammengenommen übertrifft
die liebe freunde so sieht der
militärhaushalt einer globalen großmacht
aus angesichts dieser zahlen und des
enormen unterschied der die beiden
mächte noch immer trend scheint es daher
extrem unwahrscheinlich dass china die
vereinigten staaten in bezug auf das
militärbudget zumindest in den nächsten
zwei jahrzehnten einholen könnte tja und
wenn 20 jahren wird china dann wohl mehr
mit seiner schwämme rüstiger rentner
beschäftigt sein als mit militärischer
rüstung aus dem aus pekings weltmacht
träume während somit ausgeträumt gut
dann hätten wir diese frage also auch
noch geklärt war er ein erfrischend
kurzes video heute deswegen like und abo
nicht vergessen und macht es gut los
lässt ok also gut mir fällt aber gerade
noch was ein muss china denn überhaupt
in puncto verteidigungsausgaben mit dem
amerikanischen riesen mithalten können
haben die chinesen nicht vielleicht doch
eine strategie entwickelt um dem
gigantischen militärisch industriellen
komplex der us- auf asymmetrische weise
die stirn zu bieten und vor allem dabei
auch militärisch ihre stetigen
wachsenden weltweiten claims abzustecken
die machthaber in peking werden doch
nicht herumsitzen deutschen drehen und
den amis da wachstum sehen wie sie die
welt mit ihren streitkräften dominieren
und in der tat wenn man zu diesem thema
etwas tiefer unter der oberfläche der
üblichen schlagzeilen und nachrichten
bord und recherchiert kommen sehr
interessante und überraschende
informationen zutage welche die lage
durchaus drehen könnten seid ihr
gespannt darauf alles über pekings
ausgeklügelte militärstrategie zu
erfahren gut dann nicht viel los
aber einen augenblick bevor wir loslegen
lasst mich schon jetzt gleich am anfang
eine bestimmte frage klären die ganz
ganz viele von euch in den kommentaren
gestellt haben wie finanziert sich
gründlich visual politik wer bezahlt was
also heute kommt endlich die lang
ersehnte antwort und sie lautet
sponsoren aber nicht irgendwelche random
sponsoren wenn wir schon einen sponsor
auswählen müssen wir selbst von dessen
produkt überzeugt sein und davon dass er
euch damit einen echten mehrwert bringen
wir aus vielen unserer videos west
liegen uns die themen
informationsfreiheit und sicherheit sehr
am herzen und da ich von hause aus
informatiker bin weiß ich natürlich dass
vorsorge viel besser ist als das ist
einem hinterher leid tut daher konnten
wir es nicht mit unserem gewissen
vereinbaren euch länger einfach so
ungeschützt im netz surfen zu lassen
ohne ein wirklich gutes vpn virtual
private network wird wirklich gut meine
ich eines das wirklich sicher es zum
beispiel weder datenverkehr noch meter
oder verbindungsdaten mit luft und jede
menge security tools mitbringt also wir
haben sorgfältig verglichen und am ende
kam surfen weekend heraus so scharf ist
aus vielen gründen ein ganz tolles hobby
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf
website und interne dienste zugreifen
die in dem land in dem ihr euch gerade
befindet nicht verfügbar sind ohne
zensur blocking und so weiter ob daheim
oder im urlaub aber es ermöglicht noch
viel mehr vor allem was die sicherheit
angeht hat er nicht zum beispiel auch
ein mulmiges gefühl durch die
allgegenwärtigen werbe popups und
cookies mit surft bekommt ein handliches
tool namens clean web dass sie alle
einfach blockiert und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem stalker
konto könnt ihr alle eure geräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks und sogar
euren smart tvs deckt wirklich alle
arten von geräten ihr bekommt wirklichen
lückenlosen schutz und weil wir euch
super lieb haben und gleichzeitig
verdammt harte hunde sind haben wir so
lange mit surf stadt verhandelt bis wir
für euch ein besonders städten rabat
rausholen konnten mit hilfe des
rabattcodes politik.de bekommt ihr sage
und schreibe 83 prozent rabatt und
obendrein noch die ersten drei monate
gratis dazu den link zu diesem angebot
findet ihr in der beschreibung unter
diesem video also seid keine sekunde
länger ungeschützt im netz unterwegs
sagt research und hält damit
gleichzeitig auch unseren finanzen mit
wir für euch weiterhin nette videos
drehen können so und jetzt nichts wie
los chinas clevere strategie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während der letzten 30 jahre hat sich in
china viel verändert und auch das
verständnis von armee landesverteidigung
und vor allem außenpolitik hat eine
gewaltige revolution erlebt eine
revolution die sich drei sehr
unterschiedliche phasen unterteilen
lässt
[Musik]
die erste phase in sprach nordturms
strategie der verteidigung durch einen
groß angelegten langwierigen krieg ihre
wesentliche grundlage war eine riesige
gigantische armee auch wenn sie nur
rudimentär und schlecht ausgerüstet war
pure masse wenig klasse falls nötig sei
dieser plan sogar vor selbst alle
zivilisten zu mobilisieren auch wenn sie
keine spezielle ausbildung oder
ausrüstung hatten eine art chinesischer
volkssturm die zweite phase war als 24
zeichen strategie bekannt sie wurde von
deng xiaoping vorangetrieben und
beinhaltete die beibehaltung eines
niedrigen außen politischen und
militärischen profils um die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung zu fördern
und vom rest der welt nicht als
bedrohung wahrgenommen zu werden diese
strategie blieb auch während der
präsidentschaft von chancen erhalten
obwohl sie sich in der ära hu jintao
langsam zu ändern begannen als die große
militärische modernisierung begangen die
dritte phase schließlich entspricht der
idee von rückkehr des reichs der mitte
eine strategie die von shipping durch
die sogenannte nationale verjüngung
gefördert wird sie besagt dass china
wieder zum rückgrat des politischen
lebens in asien wird zu diesem zweck hat
der chinesische diktator ausdrücklich
angeordnet dass die volksbefreiungsarmee
bis 2049 zu einer militärischen macht
ersten ranges werden soll der entschied
linken will nicht nur eine erstklassige
armee haben und china zu verteidigen
sondern sie auch nutzen um seinen
politischen einfluss bereichen zu
erweitern
und glaubt nicht alles sekunde dass das
alles nur heiße luft oder leeres
geschwätz ist die reden und vor allem
die taten des chinesischen führers
lassen keinen raum für zweifel da der
uns bewusst bemühen aus der geschichte
zu lernen um eine strahlende zukunft zu
schaffen müssen wir die modernisierung
der nationalen verteidigung unter
streitkräfte beschleunigen in
heldenhaften und zehnkampf erklären die
kbc und das chinesische volk der welt
feierlich dass die chinesischen nation
hin beginn eines großen sprungs begrüßt
vom aufstieg zu bescheidenen wohlstand
und aufkeimender stärker die chinesische
nation ist in einen unumkehrbaren
historischen prozess eingetreten wie
schinken präsident der volksrepublik
china das ist schon eine ordentliche
absichtserklärung ich war aber wie
konnte es bis zu diesem punkt kommen und
die millionen euro frage hatte chinas
öffnungs und entwicklungspolitik von
vornherein das klare und vorher
bestimmte ziel das land wieder zur
dominierenden macht auf dem asiatischen
kontinent zu machen weil ich all die
jahrzehnte die verdeckte agenda pekings
oder handelt es sich um etwas das ich
erst im laufe der zeit aus der
entwicklung der ereignisse ergeben hat
und welche verdeckte agenda fährt peking
heute nun eins nach dem anderen
tatsache ist dass bereits präsident hu
jintao schießl pinks vorgänger von 2003
bis 2013 mit deng xiaopings nicht
interventionistische visionen brach los
die an wir sollten der sicherheit auf
see im weltraum und im cyberspace große
bedeutung beimessen wir sollten den
einsatz von streitkräften in
friedenszeiten aktiv planen die
militärische bereitschaft ausbauen und
intensivieren und die fähigkeit
verbessern ein breites spektrum
militärischer aufgaben zu erfüllen von
denen die wichtigsten darin besteht
einen lokalen krieg im
informationszeitalter zu gewinnen
washington maliger präsident der
volksrepublik china er hat so sieht's
aus im gegensatz zu dem was viele denken
war es nicht der die militärische
eskalation den rüstungswettlauf los trat
natürlich hat der derzeitige führer die
dinge noch viel weiter getrieben man
denke nur an hongkong oder die ständigen
provokationen gegenteil war man könnte
fast sagen dass der unterschied zwischen
hu jintao empfing der unterschied
zwischen dem wollen und den glauben ist
wollte es und sie glaubt nun dass sich
ihr ziel bereits in reichweite befindet
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass hu jintao an stark und
schnelle modernisierung der
volksbefreiungsarmee eingeleitet hatten
vervierfachte sich während seiner
präsidentschaft der militärhaushalt in
absoluten zahlen die grenze von 150
milliarden dollar pro jahr für
verteidigungsausgaben wurde zum ersten
mal überschritten und in seinen letzten
drei amtsjahren erhöhte shintaro militär
aus alters- und 13 bis 18 prozent so
konnte china während der ära winter
seinen ersten flugzeugträger in betrieb
nehmen die ersten beiden versionen von
tarnkappen bomber auf den markt bringen
und eine ganz neue palette von
ballistischen raketen entwickeln eine
davon ist übrigens interkontinental mit
einer reichweite von bis zu 14.000 km
kann die dongfeng 41 fast jeden punkt
auf diesem planeten erreichen in den
letzten jahren der ära wurde der
grundstein dafür gelegt dass schütteln
bringen eine aktive militärische
überlegenheit in asien insbesondere
gegenüber taiwan und im südchinesischen
meer durchsetzen konnte mit anderen
worten die chinesen besitzen nun nicht
nur die waffen nein sie nutzen sie jetzt
auch aktiv das so um ihren nachbarn die
zähne zu zeigen ganz deutlich zu
demonstrieren wer hier die macht hat mit
anderen worten shipping erbte ein
wettrüsten das bereits begonnen hatte
und dass er noch ausweitete allerdings
mit einem bombastischen ziel chinas
größe wieder herzustellen vor allem nach
außen und dieses ziel zu erreichen
braucht natürlich nicht nur ein moderner
das militär sondern vor allem muss er
sich in asien mindestens auf augenhöhe
mit den vereinigten staaten befinden und
die frage lautet wie nah ist er diesen
ehrgeizigen ziel bereits gekommen tja
genau diesen knackpunkt werden wir jetzt
genau unter die lupe nehmen
die rückkehr des reichs der mitte
ob du es glaubst oder nicht ja es gibt
bereiche in denen die chinesische armee
2021 selbst die armee der usa die
mächtigste armee in der geschichte der
menschheit übertrifft konkret können wir
über drei bereiche sprechen
[Musik]
erstens das für tina über eine größere
schiffsbau kapazität welche die
chinesische marine zur größten der welt
gemacht hat technologisch und in bezug
auf die tallage liegt zwar immer noch
weiter in den usa zurück aber ihre
entwicklung und ihre wachsende kapazität
machen sie zu einem schwer zu
schlagenden gegner in einem regionalen
konflikt ein zweiter stelle stehen
bodengestützte ballistische raketen und
marschflugkörper
das chinesische militär verfügt bereits
über mehr als 1250 ballistische raketen
die in einem regionalen konflikt
eingesetzt werden können und schließlich
war für tina über das beste
luftverteidigungssystem der welt dank
der russischen s-300 und s-400 systeme
und weiterer eigener systeme ist chinas
himmel vielleicht am besten verteidigte
der welt natürlich sprechen wir im
moment und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
überregionale schlagkraft
[Musik]
in den medien stoßen wir immer wieder
auf nachrichten und berichte in die in
china im militärischen bereich als
direkter konkurrent der vereinigten
staaten bestehen wird davon kann jedoch
keine rede sein und muss sie auch nicht
die chinesische führung ist sich nämlich
vollkommen der tatsache bewusst dass die
derzeitigen defizite auf globaler ebene
enorm sind während china zum beispiel
nur zwei aktive flugzeugträger art und
ein dritter bis 2022 fertiggestellt
werden soll haben die usa 20
flugzeugträger in betrieb das ist genau
der grund warum china ist unmittelbares
ziel darin besteht eine globale
supermacht zu werden sondern vor allem
eine regionale supermacht gut jetzt
werden einige von euch sagen wie
langweilig wieso sollte uns hier eine
regionale supermacht irgendwo weit in
ostasien interessieren ok denkt noch mal
eines der gründe nach wovon hier die
rede ist von ostasien das ist nicht
irgendeine regionen wie zum beispiel
südamerika die linksregierung will nicht
weniger als das neue super zentrum der
weltwirtschaft beherrschen von denen
jede lieferkette und jede fabrik in der
ganzen welt abhängig ist das ist der
asymmetrische welteroberung plant
pekings seine militärmacht auf kluge
weise genau an dem punkt über den es die
ganze welt wirtschaftlich beherrschen
kann zu konzentrieren denn sobald dieses
ziel erreicht ist kann es wirklich sagen
alle räder stehen still wenn chinas
starker arm es will und weißt du was in
dieser hinsicht sind die dinge in der
tat viel ausgeglichener und china könnte
schon bald dazu in der lage sein die
vereinigten staaten zu übertreffen was
dabei unglaublich wichtig ist und dieses
ziel zu erreichen braucht peking weit
weniger ressourcen als das amerikanische
imperium
es ist einfach am längeren hebel denkmal
einen moment darüber nach wer die
vereinigten staaten einen riesigen ozean
überwinden müssen und deshalb zum
beispiel eine große flotte von
flugzeugträgern einsatzdienst und
militärbasen auf der ganzen welt
unterhalten müssen ist die situation des
asiatisch priesen eine ganz andere
[Applaus]
alles was die chinesische regierung
braucht sind moderne streitkräfte die in
der lage sind mit dem fertig zu werden
was die usa auf ihren basen asiatisch
pazifischen raum stationiert haben in
dieser region hat die us macht rund
350.000 soldaten 180 schiffe das sind
rund 60 prozent der gesamten us marine
und etwa 1.500 flugzeuge stationiert um
sein ziel zu erreichen muss china daher
nur diese schlagkraft der usa in der
region übertreffen und das ist genau das
was sie anstreben sich auf ihre
unmittelbare nachbarschaft zu
beschränken im rest der welt hingegen
verfolgt china eine strategie der
einflussnahme wie keinerlei
militärischen aufwand benötigt sie
widmen sich investitionen dem kauf von
unternehmen der vergabe von krediten an
entwicklungsländer und dem aufbau von
infrastruktur eine strategie die in den
kommenden jahren vielleicht viele
früchte tragen könnte die aber derzeit
keine direkten militärischen ambitionen
hat
[Musik]
denn es gibt keine notwendigkeit für
solche direkten militärischen eingriff
die welt hat sich verändert und heute
reist die kontrolle über den asiatisch
pazifischen raum aus um die gesamte
weltpolitik zu bestimmen und jeder die
lehniner irgendwo in der welt abschließt
hat vor allem ein ziel das jeweilige
land und seine wirtschaft noch stärker
von ostasien abhängig und dadurch
pekings hebel über die dortige
militärische stärke noch größer zu
machen das erklärt warum der unterschied
in den militärbudgets zwischen den usa
und china vielleicht gar nicht so
entscheidend ist wenn es dann wirklich
darauf ankommt darüber hinaus haben die
chinesen einen weiteren vorteil die
verschwommene grenze zwischen der
zivilen wirtschaft der kriegswirtschaft
und dem militär
[Applaus]
denn seit sie an die macht gekommen ist
wurden militärische aufgaben und
anforderungen die zivile infrastruktur
integriert so zum beispiel zivile bauten
zum militärische zwecke genutzt die
logistik und dies leistungskapazitäten
wurden ebenfalls genutzt um die
kapazitäten der streitkräfte zu stärken
und gleichzeitig das nationale
mobilisierungs systemen für die
verteidigung zu vertiefen und zu
erweitern
dieses zielt darauf ab alle nationalen
ressourcen für chinas militärische
aufrüstung und schließlich für einen
krieg verfügbar zu machen wenn sie also
den hebel umlegt wird alles sofort auf
kriegswirtschaft umgestellt tja und all
das von dem wir die hier gerade erzählen
hat einen namen und einen schicken titel
die military will use development
strategy kurz etf zu deutsch quasi
militärisch zivile fusions
entwicklungsstrategie zum vergleich
chinas verteidigungsindustrie war
spätestens seit montag nicht mehr so
stark mit ziviler und industrieller
technologie verschmolzen was bedeutet
das alles also im grunde genommen will
die chinesische regierung die
gesamtheitlichen logische und operative
entwicklung der chinesischen unternehmen
auf den militärischen bereich übertragen
anders ausgedrückt die chinesische
regierung will das landes zu einer
gigantischen festung und einer
unschlagbaren macht in der
asiatisch-pazifischen region machen um
dies zu erreichen ist sich in pink
bereit alle notwendigen ressourcen
einzusetzen dazu gehört auch die
ressourcen private chinesische
unternehmen und das bedeutet auch dass
der militärhaushalt in gewisser weise
nicht den vollen aufwand wieder spiegel
den china wirklich ins militär steckt
möchtest du ein konkretes beispiel sehen
nun da hätten wir zum beispiel die
sogenannte chinesische perlenkette ein
mega projekt das aus der entwicklung von
stützpunkten häfen und marine strukturen
unter der kontrolle chinesische
unternehmen vom ostchinesischen meer bis
zum mittelmeer besteht ja du hast
richtig gehört bis zum mittelmeer der
springende punkt ist nun dass das
netzwerk theoretisch eine cd und
schwerpunkt hat aber machen wir uns
nichts vor es ist sehr wahrscheinlich
dass viele seiner knotenpunkte auch
einen potenziellen militärischen nutzen
haben für ihr militär analysten ist
dieser aspekt natürlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit dh dass das
rennen zwischen den usa und china das
wirkliche rennen das rennen auf das es
ankommt vielleicht viel enger ist als
wir heute annehmen
nur eben aus einem ganz anderen grund
als uns überall in den medien erzählt
wird und diesen feinen unterschied zu
kennen ist enorm wichtig damit wir uns
auf die kommenden entwicklungen richtig
vorbereiten können lassen wir also noch
einmal zusammen die wirtschaftliche
technologische und militärische
überlegenheit der usa gegenüber china
ist immer noch gigantisch aber trotzdem
ist es nicht mehr klar dass die
amerikanischen macht china im asiatisch
pazifischen raum den neuen
wirtschaftlichen und industriellen nabel
der welt leicht überwinden könnte das
ist also wie bewaffnete globalisierung
und der camping- und die kommunistische
partei chinas träumen es geht um die
kontrolle des chores der weltwirtschaft
mit dem die ganze welt in ihrer hand
läge noch bedeutender ist dass sich ski
mit dieser strategie durchzusetzen
scheint deswegen gingen die neuen
prioritäten im weißen haus auf der
lösung oder ein denn um genau dieses
problems zum einen geht es darum chinas
militärische macht in ostasien im zaum
zu halten und zum anderen darum chinas
hebel kleiner zu machen das heißt die
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit der
weltweiten lieferketten von dieser
region zu verringern aber jetzt bist du
an der reihe was glaubst du wie die usa
und die westlichen länder im allgemeinen
die wachsende dominanz chinas in der
wichtigsten region der welt einnehmen
können wie verhält sich dein land in
dieser hinsicht macht es nicht
unabhängige wo der abhängiger wie immer
so wir auf eure meinungen zu diesem
thema gespannt ich hoffe also dass
dieses video gefallen hat falls ja gibt
uns mit nec und teils auch mit deinen
freunden machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]